في هذه الأثناء، ما نسمعه، لذا
أريدك أن تخبرني بصفتك
رئيسًا للإغاثة، أن هناك عددًا من
وكالات المعونة التابعة للأمم المتحدة، برنامج الأغذية العالمي وغيرها، والتي
يبدو أنك تعرف أن حوالي 30 مسؤولًا في الأمم المتحدة قد قاموا
بتحليل الأرقام، وقد نظروا في
ما يحدث وهم الآن  يقولون بشكل أساسي
أن غزة تظهر أه حقًا إما
مجاعة أو ظروف ما قبل الولادة المباشرة
في الوقت الحالي وأن غالبية
السكان معرضون للخطر، علاوة على ذلك
يقولون إنهم لم يروا مثل هذا،
هذه هي الأمم المتحدة في العشرين عامًا الماضية في
أي مكان حول
العالم.  لقد كان جانبًا استثنائيًا ومقدسًا
غير مرحب به من
حرب الجازين المسيحية، كما تقول إنها
جلبت المجاعة، وبمثل هذه
السرعة المذهلة إلى مقدمة
خطوطنا، يوجد ما يقل قليلاً عن
400000 شخص في هذا القسم الذي
يعد من الناحية الفنية  توصف بأنها معرضة
لخطر المجاعة وهي
الفئة الأكثر تطرفًا من
انعدام الأمن الغذائي وكما تقول العديد من وكالات الأمم المتحدة
الآن اليوم والأمس
تقول أن
400.000 الغالبية العظمى منهم في
الواقع في مجاعة ليس فقط في خطر
المجاعة ولكن في المجاعة الآن  أعني أنه إذا
أخذت ذلك
جنبًا إلى جنب ووضعته جنبًا إلى جنب مع
الصعوبات التي نواجهها في إيصال
المساعدات إلى 300,000 شخص ما زالوا
يعيشون في شمال غزة والذين
بالطبع لم يحصلوا على أي مساعدات إنسانية
لبعض الوقت، فإنك تقلق حقًا
بشأن ذلك  محنة مستقبل سكان غزة
وأنت قلق للغاية بشأن
الكراهية بين الأجيال التي
ستخلقها هذه الحقائق، وبالتالي
نحن قلقون على أمن إسرائيل بقدر قلقنا على
أمن الحكم في
القضية الإنسانية التي تقول إسرائيل إنها
لديها  هناك عدد من المعابر المفتوحة سواء
من إسرائيل نفسها أو من مصر،
وهذا في الواقع يضعون العبء عليك وعلى
المجتمع الإنساني، كما يقولون،
إذا لم تتمكن من الوصول إلى هناك بالسرعة الكافية،
فهذا ليس عليهم نعم، لقد سمعت هذا
وأنا أنا  لا تجده
حكما عادلا صحيح أن هناك
نقطتين أه
للدخول إلى غزة واحدة عبر معبر رفح
والأخرى أه عبر كيسون
والتي كانت الحكومة الإسرائيلية
جيدة بما فيه الكفاية لفتحها أمام حركة المرور
وهناك جيدة  تخطط لزيادة حركة المرور
عبر
منطقة كاروم ولكن هذه هي
النقطة التي يمكنك من خلالها إدخال الشاحنات ولكن
إذا لم تتمكن من الاعتماد على
عدم تعارض طرق الوصول إلى الأشخاص
المحتاجين إذا لم تتمكن من إعادة التأكيد على
عدم تعرض المستشفيات للهجوم على الأقل في مكان قريب إذا لم
تتمكن من الاعتماد على الأشخاص الذين لديهم  الانتقال
من مكان يعاني من انعدام الأمن إلى مكان آخر يعاني من
انعدام الأمن، تلك هي القضايا التي
تجعل تسليم المساعدات الإنسانية ليس
مسألة عدد الشاحنات التي
يمكن أن تصل، إنها مسألة الوصول إلى داخل غزة
أه التي تشمل عناصر
القيد وهذا  حيث كنا
باستمرار، وكما قال الأمين العام
باستمرار، إنه
من الجيد بالفعل أن نحصي الشاحنات التي
تدخل ولكن القصة تبدأ فقط
بأنها لا تنتهي عند هذا الحد فقط لكي
نكون واضحين قبل السابع من أكتوبر، كان هناك 500 شاحنة
يوميًا  يصل الآن الحد الأقصى إلى 127، وقد
أخبرني السيناتور الأمريكي كريس فان هولاند
أنه في الواقع يضع الأمر على عاتق
السلطات الإسرائيلية لتحريك التدفق
لأنه عندما تتحدث عن منع الاشتباك،
قال إنه حتى آلية
فحص الشاحنات
صعبة للغاية و  كما تعلم أنه يجب
إعادتهم باستمرار، فهناك أيضًا
استخدام واسع النطاق لفئة الاستخدام المزدوج
من قبل أولئك الذين يقومون بفحص الشاحنات، وكان
لدينا الكثير من المعدات الطبية والصحية التي تم
تفسيرها على أنها ذات
استخدام مزدوج، وبالتالي  يتم إرجاع الشاحنة
ولا يُسمح لها بالدخول و و و و
أخيرًا في هذا الشأن وبالإشارة إلى
500 شاحنة يوميًا، ما نتذكره جميعًا
بوضوح هو أن 80٪ من
القوت
قبل 7 أكتوبر كان من
القطاع الخاص وقد جادلنا
طوال الوقت  من فضلكم دعوا القطاع الخاص
يعمل، ولا يمكنهم العمل إلا
بأمان، نعم بالطبع